[ __ ] oh my god dad what if he's
welding you now I'm sore I got my mm had
a rough one yesterday after I saw you
rough one I got in that fight uh-huh but
yeah I didn't up you add in another
Street flight to your bill I I don't
even like talking about this and I don't
want to talk about how many is this a
thousand uh it's a lot it's enough don't
be a dick dude I'm I got man I know but
I got it you know I'm not gonna if I
tell you that I you're gonna go to it I
got a night it's not funny it was United
of a sample yeah I got in a scuffle and
your sword from it yeah I'm sore from
linka discolour you know street fight
really lasts less than 60s yeah and this
lasted you want it I mean he's gonna be
a dick God just be honest you are now
how long I lasted yes with whatever with
the chase and everything oh there is a
chase car chase or foot chase both don't
be a dick like yeah I nice like yeah so
I'm driving I'll touch do you want to
hear it you've got to give me the plot
from Grand Theft Auto I'm not going to
give you the plot I'm driving in minding
my own business I'm on the the right
hand lane and a guy drives by this woman
in her SUV and takes his bike lock and
smashes her window hello calls her a
[ __ ] well and she starts to cry and he
takes off down the way but I'm all the
way on the other side so I have to cut I
just instinctively go I go stay there
and she was like you said that to her
yeah did you ask her what she did wrong
I could tell if she did nothing wrong
cuz she goes I didn't do anything on the
situation she goes I didn't do anything
wrong and I go I know stay there captain
save-a-ho was here I I'm sorry
captain save-a-ho
I'm trying to tell story for all of your
Laurel idling this is in Venice yes in
setting alright I don't know that I got
any DK so I make I make a right I've
shut up Ross all traffic and I chase him
down the way and I'm trying to I'm
trying he's on a bike and I'm chasing
him he's on a body in my Tesla
hello and so he's moving pretty quickly
and I like a Pullo I will blow over
and then he goes [ __ ] you is young like
a huffy or not I'm like wait Harley not
he's alright no he's on a huffy I got
okay like a bike so he pulled in I
clipped his wheel goes down so I pull
over and I jump out and then he gives
chase well don't say gives - he he why I
left so I left
so he's white he's white with Prison
tattoos everywhere and he was a big guy
probably relation origination guy wife
beater tattoos yeah rough yeah yeah it
said like sweats hate yep yep yep yep
and so I left upon him and as I left
upon him he swung his [ __ ] so I left
here I well I love you like jump on them
like belly me the belly need about here
okay and then he like give me your hand
warm hold my coffee and half koala table
Olli hold up okay and he was here in and
he goes he grabbed me around my hips
here okay okay and I was like girl
already get up and I then he brought his
hands up and he [ __ ] put him around
my dad yep like this and then I was like
this so you guys are doing yeah and we
were like this okay then and then he he
goes he goes he goes I'm kiss you and I
go for that [ __ ] off me like I'm gonna
try I'm gonna fight us I guess I got
[ __ ] children I'm showing you what I
did
I'm showing you the point is I got
enough [ __ ] funnyman sorry his
[ __ ] sorry I know my not eating I
thought man he had a full beard you
lucky in [ __ ] yeah well he tried trying
to making out with you I heard low yeah
we go T I oh what the [ __ ] in any shirt
we had a pitbull that tried to bite oh
my god man so I had to I sleep - yeah
hog don't have really girl the girl I
came back yep and she was going 1 to 10
what she looked like she was if I can go
to 10 10 6 and try hooking up we should
go change a real and I was like what and
she showed me her better I married she
goes I won't tell I go no way I'm
married no way and then she goes just
touch him yeah you gotta do it you know
yes justice it's yeah just it's justice
I held them in my hands for a while just
[ __ ] you [ __ ] kill the Hatfield oh
wait is your titty [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
no no that would be I'm over to all
mothers here it would be cheating or
it's what heroes do while it is what
heroes do but Bruce Wayne does I was
like I was like you earned this yeah -
guys them together I'll put this justice
pipe between them did you say captain
save-a-ho yeah I did yeah her double for
no that's very funny
yeah captain save oh yeah a lot of
energy this one bro yeah I do bro
you know I think gave you the energy
what happened he's guilty boots yeah I
mean song girls on the phone making
deals and Layton you come in yeah like
they yeah they're just over the line
aren't they other too much well instead
you know they're just over the line it's
too much if you were a Scottish bagpiper
and you had bagpipes and a kilt then
even then I go even so we're a little
over there a little bit too much even
then so no you know what let's take it
down I'd say yeah those are great
take the buckle off can you cut the
buckle off no the buckle I celebrate
there's two like serpent heads on it
it's a very game of throne ish I know
but it's not you're not a no hand up
than Janice Danny from the 1500s
will show us I know they would go well
for the guy for the Kings you get a
little head cut off all of the other but
I sure did see them go bumblebee I sure
that you you just love you love I'm
surprised you don't wear jewels what do
you mean just confuse yeah like you just
don't why don't you wear jewels you know
like like a lotto right now a lot of
diamonds or like a lot of bracelets and
rings yeah you love God like a ring so
it you know what I like rings amen yeah
like a bracelet if they're cool gray so
it's cause like Bono
fuzzy ambition I have all sorts of cool
stuff Artie Lange said that his
father would never let you open his car
doors if you had rings on don't open my
car door you get it right well yeah the
[ __ ] the doors it'll-it'll huh that's a
common thing yeah you you takes do it
really like that a long time that I was
dating girl she had this person she like
SWAT like I don't know you know [ __ ]
person she had to go I mean kinda scrape
to Shelly car and then she had heels on
she put her legs up like this and the
high-heeled went into the dashboard ha
ha oh my god that'll make you crazy
knocked it up a little ha oh yeah and
that's all you can think of well you
can't get rid of it yeah I you you
helped me act man I I dented my test
Levin you pulled it out yeah I told it
out that's good
some get scratches huh yeah what
happened exactly got a little mad right
I don't we bad mmm gotta fight mmm we'll
know it's like you can you keep saying
get in place I got a hot temper but I
know what happened you know it is you
don't tell people I'm gonna tell people
don't for another time no hey you don't
tell people I can't mean I want to tell
people no because I'll tell you why
later no Brian if you don't give people
an ideal you're so bad and you through
age to two of your best friend huh I'm
gonna tell everybody I don't know what
you're talking about
really I don't I'm gonna give you one
more opportunity and then I'm gonna
squeal like a pig thought you were
making fun of my birthday party
me you and Rogan and I had to you
thought me and Rose were making slitting
throats gentille if that fit you and I
got a little mad because I was like it's
mother [ __ ] and making fun of my
birthday party and the night cuz cuz I
pulled in and I died I [ __ ] my car up
cuz I I misjudged when I still hate him
I hate at me in my own driveway and I do
hate ya and I go I got all these mother
[ __ ] just wrecked my car well you
wrecked your car see these [ __ ]
wrecked my car
you thought me and him we're making for
your birthday party yeah I thought you
were talking behind my back about my
birthday party and so I was like oh my
two really good friends talking man
back ok about a birthday [ __ ] you guys
how about that and maybe we're not
friends anymore I want that last out I
last out a little bit without and then
on me but then I'm gonna play something
I'm gonna play something we had a talk
to I was like yeah well don't [ __ ]
diss my family and don't diss my
birthday party and I and you're like hey
hey slow down dude what the [ __ ]
yeah we're friends man I was like yeah
well then I was like oh my god I can't
stay mad you know me I can say mad for
how long that's what I'm looking got the
next morning I mean that is so
disrespectful
I'm personally [ __ ] outraged I'm so
mad you're a little hothead come back
from San Francisco I get hot bro you run
hot I get I got a lot of attention in my
head like just I'll make up stories in
my head
me too I know you do that's why I know
you understand sets a little seed and
then I'll be like there's a little scene
if at all of the whole situation go
through my head like it really happened
then I'll see the person I know why do
we do that what is that about is that
like a do I need to go work out or
something no I think it's the creative
part of us like my imagination right
yeah my brain to run while I do that
I've done that I would do that with my
father I do that could you think back
about a fight that you had were you or
something and you go what if it went
even further and then what if it went
and then what if they said this and I
say that's me like what am i doing or I
was on a business call yesterday and you
know like duh well they decide to do
this like oh no problem I have the phone
I bet this happened not that he calls
him and then and I could call again with
them today already I assumed that
happened oh my god yeah you make
pre-conceived you're already ready you
got your guns locked and loaded well are
you going fine I'm good
I don't get went down
but it never happened it never happens
weird Todd Phillips you know the
director of hang around smart guy Todd
always says when he makes a movie like
he always says you got to keep everyone
in the same movie and everybody's going
to always think the movies about them in
one way or another everybody wants to
contribute but but everybody blows their
own roll up out of proportion and
everybody's got to be a team player and
sometimes you got to take a step back
and that's part of what a director has
to do is to keep everybody kind of like
in their lane and he said that gig it's
a very tell Akhil Jackson to the skull
incorrect it's a very good every movie
yes and I've you know he's very good at
good it's you've got to be it sometimes
it takes a special individual very much
so and he said people in life do this
and I've heard writers say this because
usually everybody who is in your life
with the exception of the main people
but even then they're not trying to
undermine you necessarily but you're
certainly kind of a footnote you that
embarrass the [ __ ] out of myself at that
party I was such an idiot that's all
they must be talking about no they're
not you're not that important they're
not that important it's not that you're
not that important they're looking
they're busy with their lives you're
busy with your life you think it's
better deal than it is yes yes you think
it's a bigger deal than this where
people go dude I'm so sorry I mean an
idiot and myself I don't even remember
it I'm like what what do you mean oh my
god is that how you thought sorry I
didn't see it that way
no I have to meet with a mental coach
after I lost my urn my first life after
one of the fights that I lost because I
felt like every room I went there like
oh my god there's Fishburne shoppi
you got knocked up by my okay remember
guys that's kid who got knocked up by
Nogueira everywhere I went I had anxiety
like soon as I was walk-in it was in
Denver so you know I'm kind of a famous
fighter in Denver so when I'd walk in a
restaurant or coffee shop he would look
sure well I thought they're looking on
all barriers there's guy not that they
kept rolling over over in my mind and
I'd be sitting on my comp I gotta
probably watch on the phones oh my god I
can't believe I had to meet was so on
and then I said same things like mmm not
that like I realize it's a big fight for
you in your career the grand scheme of
things we're not going to promise you
they're not saying it is what they're
thinking is that guys that badass fights
in the UFC or they're not even like you
think they're looking they're not those
are something else or those looking at
your ears your size but they're not like
oh my that's guy
knocked out like isn't literally
overwhelming oh my god hey we had a
friend who was this really good-looking
dude he was this big
really handsome guy and when you go out
with him and girls would look at him and
he probably wasn't gonna win any rocket
science Awards yeah though man you'd see
him and he'd be like [ __ ] like what
[ __ ] girl [ __ ] staring at me
because he thinks I'm stupid huh right
no she doesn't
thanks you know she doesn't know why
would you be staring at me like huh no
because I put on a [ __ ] shirt that
they don't like know anything that your
shirts footboard good-looking [ __ ] I
look at you yeah he was a I have to have
that problem around comedians so sure
they're well-known comedians on the
greenroom they walk they're like oh boy
I've seen II hate me I've seen you walk
in I'm the Builder I'm like right away
I'm like are they [ __ ] hate me
they're gonna make fun of me here we go
I think I'm like this Qi back there we
go and then they come up to I came in
I'd like like Dane Cook to say I do the
nicest ever yeah and like they're
awesome to me of course right I'm like
oh my god here we go
get ready footnote first all no one's
ever done me the first time roads it's
my own insecurities first I'm totally in
the green room I'm a rose in the green
room with a bunch of other hitters and
you came in after doing a set and you
literally you your shoulders were
hunched up and you're you you were
looking down and I go hey and you go so
yeah I go what happened I'm trying buddy
the taste in your forearms legs
yeah I don't want to like I've never
seen like that you're like I'm sorry I'm
what I don't want all just for being in
the room I don't want to burst in right
yeah
user news for 20 years it's [ __ ]
hilarious and I know that way anyway we
weren't even thinking that I don't know
Allanon students well we all do that
yeah an act in acting school of course
is the greatest because when you're in
acting school they call walking in with
apology and when you go into an audition
room it's like what do you really get
really you come up there on stage and
they go Jeffrey Tambor would go um what
are you apologizing for what are you
apologizing for huh I didn't say
anything yeah well what is your body
doing yeah I'm not casting you next
really next Jesus I think if you get off
stage and then you'd have to come back
out an hour later do you want to try
this again are you going to come in like
like you did just Excel right away yeah
I want to see I want to see a
[ __ ] can you be a [ __ ]
you forgot I guess for big guys like
that maybe for four girls live in
security so they're probably like new
outside so I'm like well me I don't have
confidence did you you know you know it
was shocking to me was that this is a
weird I've never told this story but I
was in his class and it was a very
intimidating place to be because it was
hard to get into that school in a way to
get into certain fine detail what people
were working though and jeffrey tambor
was this Emmy Award winning actor who I
was a huge fan of you still killed it oh
my god he's destroying he never stops
working and he said to me he goes I did
see him because you know what we have
here - we got an esteem problem you have
low self-esteem and you walk around like
you're a second class citizen and I was
probably 30 I don't know 30 to 31 dead
girl lid I was a fully grown man and and
I realized also that I couldn't audition
for men in their 40s and 50s especially
in suits
I couldn't audition for men in their
suit lady thing well because I they
reminded me of my father uh and so I was
I would freeze up that it should and I
also felt like I wasn't I was a I always
felt like I'm a kid yeah and I felt like
I wasn't I also felt like I was not a
serious adult because I was an emotional
artist yeah so those are businessmen so
yeah men who do work who go to work or
drink black coffee Italy look they're
men they don't date they they do the
things my father did with they're not
emotional they get the job done and I
was an emotional artist so I felt
feminine I felt with weak and I had to
overcome that that that was I didn't get
over that in shows
boy you have you overcome - yeah you see
I I think I could overcome as now how to
deal with it right I don't know a little
bit yeah always you're looking yeah but
what I the reason I think I'm over it
now to an extent I've embraced my own
like the power that that is being a
comedian and art yeah because they go I
know some pretty successful people who
are in suits who are in awe of what I do
well when they say sander
the way I being off a brain surgeon but
you get older does and these people
become your colleagues yeah and then
then then the science of accomplishment
starts to break down where you go you're
really good at being assertive I didn't
know that you did it only ever you
probably shouldn't get rid of all of it
no like that it's okay what they're
doing I was watching that
defiant one so you see that documented
document it's a four-part series on HBO
okay it's a Jimi Levine IV no Jimmy
Iovine and dr. Dre oh you see what other
defiant one yeah if you see what that
Jimmy guy has done in music where he's
worked with Bruce Springsteen you'd
literally everybody helps really is it
everybody but they asked Bruce
Springsteen what makes Jimmy I've been
so special and he said so he got to
start working on Bruce Springsteen's
record Born to Run I think is that one
of them but um that the sound engineer
didn't show up and Jimmy was just a
assistant like getting coffee and they
go [ __ ] the guy's not here we see you
hang around I'm not your doing and he
was like yep sure do never look back and
I was ridiculous career working with
literally everybody yeah but they're
having Jimmy Iovine Iove he's famous
I've heard of CAA he was on American
Idol as a judge all that but they that's
Bruce Springsteen what makes him special
and I come so interesting because a lot
of people I know with success have the
same problem if he goes you know he was
a guy who you know to get to that level
of success with a musician athlete
whatever it there's this drive and the
selfishness that never ever leads and as
you get older he got a change he's a guy
who that what done those those kind of
talents I'd gotten to the top where you
know you gotta be like this pitbull and
just it's all about you he's been able
to shed that and make it you know cuz
now he's at the top he's been able to
shed those kind of things and be more
giving and appreciative and he's not so
like you know tense yeah which Bruce
Springsteen goes most people never shed
that's anyways he's one way so he became
more generous more generous but also
like the idea of me me me taketake thing
want what lights just that the drive
yeah he's been able to
chill that out right I'll see has to
billion dollars I played show up to but
he's been out of those kind of because a
lot of people never lose like you know
people did this run none well we were
talking about Don stop talking about
this yesterday
you can we know a lot of successful
people and some of them are successful
and driven by a deep insecurity a hole
they can never fill yeah others are
driven by inspiration and I think that
you want to get to a point you you can
change it you know you want to get to a
point of big talk I don't know if anyone
can but yeah well I think people can if
they take see a lot of its perspective
like as I get older I think a lot of
times I do think you have strong
personality traits that are almost
impossible to shed for sure but
sometimes like perspective can help you
take a different tact if it's if it
makes sense to you rationally and even
emotionally that kind of what's going to
inform your art what's going to keep it
going is to do what Eileen did then
sometimes you can change because you can
you can refocus your energy on other
people on a different mission on sort of
how this is actually making you better
but you have to do that it's really
really difficult it's funny though
because you know he he came from rock
and roll and he didn't really know
hip-hop at all she starts to working
with Dre and you know there's the Suge
Knight stuff all that and he's like jobs
like what he was like Jesus Christ and
Suge Knight would come to his house and
stuff like that but you know he didn't
know what type of animals he was dealing
with really like he saw them as business
partners but you know they're still
gangsters well Suge Knight yeah of all
the guys you know that he's working with
snoop and they just release doggystyle
and snoop you know goes on trial for
murder you know like so he's like what
is the what the [ __ ] is going on in it
yeah and then they're saying when he
made the deal with Apple he's always
wanted to work with apples so they sell
beats by dre to Apple for four or five
billion dollars so he gets you know like
three billion dollars two billion
dollars and Ray gets two billion dollars
to fake bacon beats together yeah so
check this out so he tells Dre listen
don't say anything till it's inked we
could lose the deal t say anything dr.
Dre gets drunk with Tyrese in Malibu and
Tyrese makes a video going yeah [ __ ]
Compton's first billionaire
and they're like see walkin and they're
taking shots of vodka and then Pete
Jimmy goes P Diddy called me like you
sold Apple he's like I can't talk about
man which I the kids were really close
he's like wish we talked about it you
know I just can't talk to you right now
hangs up the phone he goes well and they
called P Diddy Kong's negatives [ __ ] I
just saw Tyrese and Dre talked about it
on Facebook
Jimmy was a client back hangs up ghost
it was like oh my god and he thought
they lost the deal the 600 please like I
know my stomach and doctor is like this
the most embarrassing moment of my life
like really yeah he goes with you know
we got drunk he goes I got drunk I'm not
sure two billion dollars like and I was
with my friends I told them and then it
is like one of most embarrassing times
oh my god can you imagine oh my god no
that kind of stuffy you know though I
mistake ah one mistake really and then
Jimmy O's were this close to losing the
deal got an apple still you know turned
off of it in my crazy yeah that's a you
gotta watch that hit Jamie his story's
crazy I can't wait to watch boy he had a
set of eyebrows when he was young
yeah my Jimmy I having word didn't he my
god it's distract you want to see the
greatest eyebrows of all time ah that
should be tough to beat him who put up
and put on Brezhnev please please we'll
get those only go to Jimmy's right here
right here now those are some brows hold
on some heavy that's a unibrow so it's
Patti Smith that's Bruce Springsteen
that Jimmy Iovine high-stress first hit
with Bruce Springsteen I wrote called so
does the night yeah but you know how
that happened Bruce was like I'm not
playing upon the album
Jimmy takes it gives it to her goes
please sing this and she goes ah
whatever doesn't look it up don't lick
it up weeks go by and then she sees the
tape laying around her husband at the
time her man was late she's I got [ __ ]
I'll listen to it wrote the lyrics he
came home at midnight next day shows up
and I guess Jimmy was obsessed like
cholera non-stop so then Jimmy goes
disaster he goes yeah I wrote some
lectures let me hear it because the
night belongs to us his work ethic was
crazy like so Nine Inch Nails everyone
who knows
yeah of course so Nine Inch Nails was
under than orrible contract kind of disc
I should say they had issues with the
people that are signed with this label
so Jimmy would call the label owner cuz
he thought Nine Inch Nails was like the
big thing like I'm telling us they're
man's right he's gonna be the biggest
thing in the world well you're here
Jimmy called that the guy who owns his
late the Nine Inch Nails writes every
single morning for a year straight call
them every morning every morning Sam
come on man come on man come on let's do
this
bye guys like [ __ ] it here we go the
Nine Inch Nails the artists of the head
singing of nine inch nails cuz we they
had a median Jimmy Neitzel underneath
he's got Trent Reznor he's the I thought
yous brilliant yes he thought so he
meets with amigos what do you want man
he goes I just wanna be left alone I'll
give you I'll give you the the album so
it please leave me alone Jimmy was done
and he goes really is ya done with us
join us and I won't be able to sign my
own talent getting us done what else
he's like the [ __ ] going on here
what's the catch - no catch man you
billion let you do your thing so he
signs mailing man said that you know
that kid goes this discreet when Reza
nurse I'm a man down there in Amsterdam
did people like this blow my mind he
just got here we had a wiring in his
brain where he can see he can hear
what's special yeah well Jimmy saw that
saw him seems like oh my god that guy's
gonna revolutionize music of course he's
brilliant and so just that that Nine
Inch Nails lead singer goes hit this
album just for free like this is just
cuz I want to get it out
I don't care about money here just it
just gave it to ya and she was like
really like dad's put it out and it like
blew up god damn he's so brilliant can
you put on can you just put estimating I
can't wait to watch this just brezhnev
because I got I got a beat brazenness
yeah he's a that Russian Russian uh-oh
hey God well this is nice there you go
look like about those huh you have a
mustache on your for me that's right he
was the Russian he was he with the
Russian premier and there you go how's
that look well those are those are Ernie
and Bert good looking guy
the guy the worst I wrote you not you
got me got me there guy now those are
the heaviest eyebrows would say two
giant capitalism that was when the
Soviet Union was very communist and holy
schnike yeah you think well I guess in
Russia when I get those guys [ __ ] but in
general italic without tough probably
brew cycle Jimmy I'm at eyebrows bro
let's do some about it I told you the
story when I went to Russia in 1989 and
I'd ever and I'm not kidding when I say
this there were no look at his body
there pull him up there there there were
no um two good-looking guys live so -
there were literally literally no old
men yeah
because they'd all died in the war huh
crazy man Russia went through some [ __ ]
man crazy I know also can talk about
that Jimmy and he said Jimmy said Bruce
was the guy who showed him work ethic
his Bruce was like there's no hours here
like there's a project you know so it
took him seven months to write this
album he was like you know if you're
playing work 9:00 to 5:00 and you can't
get the [ __ ] out right is it in I guess
Bruce just a drum like a crappy would
sit there he'll nope maybe there for
this documentary I was calling Oprah
Mills and then with Jimmy was like you
know I would get that nine you know I
said be done by 5:00 and then Bruce was
like the job I ain't done I mean if you
think like this was just a regular hours
job and you're the wrong world well I
think was Nils young knows lane
whoever's named his piano said in this
documentary the promise when they were
making the album after born run they
were making darkness on the edge of town
I think goes with the almond he goes I
would I had a feeling and I would chew a
piece of tinfoil to because it hurt so
badly to keep myself awake because I
couldn't fall asleep with Bruce because
he would just be like out you see him he
go I don't like it I do it again alright
and he was Jimmy said nothing we just
said they went through coffee energy
dressing like after a while he was I
fall asleep at the controls
Bruce like let's do it man they wake up
and just get back to work it's
incredible Springsteen energy was the
constant but he would play to the crowd
- yeah he played for four hours and then
he would go back to his hotel room and
he would take a thesaurus and he would
write Springs he would just start
writing said they'd never seen anything
like it boss
I mean I got a chance to talk to him for
an hour and a half because he's my hero
you know spring soon and I said did you
ever want to write a book or something
goes now why I said what do you mean
because I didn't want to dilute my
message and what I was capable of all
manners he went into writing songs yeah
why would you write a book like Isaac
right he just kidding all the book he
did it finally but it'd be like you know
he's [ __ ] amazing man that and that
and also he can tell people your hour
and a half conversation while I take a
piss with Bruce take I want you to I
want you to pee and I'm gonna I'm gonna
keep this train going alright buddy you
go have fun with those boots alright
those fences those offensive boots yes I
did talk to her now yes I did it was an
out Jeremy Piven can attest that Jeremy
was there yeah I don't like your face
right now there's another girl minute
hours I'll call Jeremy right now I'll
call him right now I'm calling him right
now door open
hey Jeremy can you tell the people that
I was there for an hour and half yeah I
was there for here's their front out I
believe you Brian thanks buddy I really
did talk I was the last guy out of his
dressing room is a little inappropriate
and then I saw him again six months
later and I panicked and made an idiot
of myself I couldn't unfold my arms I
was pointing my elbows at him I was like
hi and then I ran out of the book store
you get starstruck with actual people
like a Springsteen I do nobody else okay
so I mean I've had talked to Tom Cruise
I did a reading with him you know it's
fun to talk to them but you know I kind
of that's not a mystery to me
what Springsteen does or did was it is a
mystery he is that kind of effort like
anybody who decided that they were going
to be great and became great you know
there's some people who get us an
inkling that they have the ability to do
something original and something very
special and then they do it so if I
write a book I'll do an album but then
there are some people and I would put
bono u2 in this
put the beetles I'd put Springsteen who
keep doing it over and over again for a
long time they a long time ultimately
everybody plateaus I think ultimately
when you have a billion dollars children
responsibilities it becomes very
difficult but Springsteen was a guy who
and I would make this I confidently say
that he probably could have made 50
million dollars on just commercials
alone maybe more and he said no to every
single endorsement every single
endorsement so one of the favorite
pastimes is to go through his go through
in his mind the things he could buy or
how much money he'd had if he actually
did a commercial or let his music be
used in a commercial but he says no
every time and like there's a purity to
that guy there's a purity and there's a
there's a there's a decision to be
uncompromising uncompromising great
artists are difficult and great artists
are uncompromising they just refuse to
compromise that's the responsibility of
being original and that's the
responsibility of being genius you know
whoever it might be
you know I'm listening this course on
Einstein right now it's fascinating he
redefined reality redefined the idea of
what space like space and time are what
light is you miss a lot of important
stuff man you are a lot of important
stuff [ __ ] your line side [ __ ]
you're right hey man don't say it
[ __ ] alright are you regurgitated
the lights on you weren't even here bro
was that what it was just know that
brand new I never had no time and light
and distance and share redefine reality
bro I know man I start talking when I
sign this guy this guy literally is like
bored I was like oh god I'm just trying
to hang out man well I'm sorry that I
rattled your brain I'm sorry I wasn't
about it gucchi does around my brain I
really need you to regurgitate oh ha ha
we're shoes with buckles on them stop
talking to me you've lost all
credibility you [ __ ] pilgrim you all
[ __ ] pilgrim I know your eyes forever
I would be brighter friend you gotta
save this ship for your friend
throughout here you know I got lunches
like bro and you don't know why I
started laughing what do you do not know
you go like this you go yeah I go am i
boring you know no you're not I just how
do i watch the whole documentary on
Einstein where went over in detail das
so to have you have Kim through it is
painful well come on it was all set not
like I also went to school like we
covered Einstein yeah but for you to go
but I hear your brother you know I'm
saying I was just telling you a story
about who he had an experience which
chained redefine our reality but you
were I can't talk to you right now
anyway because you have all bro you had
brothers and father yes there's no but
you should do it all ice climb podcast
it just like you told me it look like it
feel free hey guys this is all things
Einstein hey guys what's the deal with
the theory of relativity and as you know
he had to refocus his energy on life
being part of with you and I really just
want hey with your boys and then you
were just wouldn't shut up about I
finally do I would see me a few days and
you are just I know I love life and what
to the next guy
let's just hang man you know I've been
working all day on her Springs and
working all days wanna chill man hanging
talk yeah I just be a dude yeah yeah I
guess it doesn't get a little heavy a
little heavy little boring though he's
always like by the way yeah you know so
Pythagorean theorem right yeah boy we
ran to Kenny Florian though oh yeah
Timmy just moved to bed my open a
jujitsu school logistical in Santa
Monica now in Culver City Santa Monica I
think he said Culver City hey being look
it up yeah look it up hey I'm pod I'm
gonna read off the address right now cuz
I tweeted it and talked to him last
night
oh yeah here run off sorries in
Barrington Barrington correct it right
Santa Monica West LA but ya know it's
cent he quit [ __ ] a man it's Santa
Monica here it is it's um mr. 41 107
[ __ ]
one above its 1 1 677 Santa Monica
Boulevard and it is myrrh Meraki jiu
jitsu the Kenny Florian is partner Jason
hunt they just had their like soft
opening and then they're doing their
grand opening go check it out and don't
be surprised if you see me rolling
rolling on that mat kicking some tails
yeah rolling around just put it on a
couple of ditches howa Kenny's moved on
by us there it is that that close to
your house beat rocky jiu-jitsu ah close
enough close enough for me to start
taking my training a lot more seriously
you could be Kenny's uh Posey well the
first thing I'm gonna go out do is buy
six keys might as well right by a bunch
of G's have them in my car at all times
well there's a question for you
fulfilling your potential be well I need
to be JJ I'm gonna walk in there and go
you guys
you guys keep striking - no masks oh if
they need a striking coach you guys need
a striking coach I said do some boxing
and my feet I kill you with my feet
tell you what though Kenny knows is Jiu
Jitsu yeah you guys yeah yes he does
I know what cause I've always said
there's just not enough to juice through
gyms in Los Angeles if you're gonna go
to one though go to Florence
there's some good [ __ ] to no way out
there it's kind of a mecca right there's
some great [ __ ] in LA I mean you have
two great the Academy got Crohn's
everywhere Kenny has his hands full guys
hands full
yeah super full he made 145 before I
Kenny back and killed himself yeah spot
Joe see all that 145 how big would you
guys know person how big is he like
normally one he walks around I've asked
him a couple times he probably weighs
180 so remember he fought it
uh he's not one of you right now he's
just compete in jiu-jitsu so he's
definitely definitely in the best shape
I've seen him in yeah yeah but remember
Teddy fought at 85
yeah that's all fifty five forty paint
did he fight you three was it BJ Penn or
was it Kenny who fought Lyoto Machida uh
BJ Penn thought okay Kenny number five
yeah Kenny fought DJ he fought BJ you
fought Sean Sherk
is what I mean thought cuz they all
though yeah how about yeah it's not a
lot of dudes yep I think he played you
on soccer right pretty sure you don't
realize how old tennis is how old is he
42 yeah that makes sense
really well I Jessica's got a long
career a long time yeah 41 41 funny good
fighter one man goddamn doing the you'll
see tonight stuff you know what staying
retiring I wonder if if it's gonna how
about I go Kenny how about Stan
Natalia's yeah he the gallery works for
is gonna buy town these are my town it
was a great opportunity um yeah I'm
gonna wait never quite guita go me damn
right oh that the Roger worked one was
so because at the time Roger worked or
was such a big name he's on the front
cover of Sports Illustrated him and I
need him no slouches I know Joe Lausanne
one was good cousin Sam Boston
Hutton Broomfield but is the to Boston
kids fighting when I Sam Scott Scottsman
if I had been fighting for that long all
stamps outs on the originals man
he fought Dean Thomas - oh yeah do you
can chose everyone men
no Kenny people for your K is a real
best you know Kenny was on Oprah
no bring up Kenny on Oprah did is they a
Dana White Kenny Fiat who else but it
was basically I'm pretty sure was Oprah
and then to their time out like mixed
martial arts and how it's not like I'm
sure maybe a different I'm sure Oprah
has or [ __ ] oh it's Canada if it's kind
of a bad boxer why is your face all
scratched up or is it uh you know we
don't link in there that's just YouTube
[ __ ] uh you know I think it was I
think I was dr. Phil you might be
variety in civil check didn't dr. Phil
get a start with Oprah yes he did yeah
there you go that that's the thing right
there and who Dan right there it is way
enough force and Kenny talked to street
fighting teens run at page Jack's on dr.
Phil does doctor feel still killed it I
think so
yeah I think it's telling there dude I
play you
see USC dr. Phil yeah no where'd he play
play too hot in New Orleans I think I'm
worth yeah he's a big dude he's a big
dude yep I like him I don't like to show
really but I like him I'll tell you he
was killing you
she has to have the biggest shown in
[ __ ] in America is Allen when you look
at her guests like oh my god it was like
Will Smith you know freaking for me
Avery but my favorite my favorite female
comedian of all time Ellen she'll
monitor it what got her to the dance the
comedy that got her to the dance to me
really and and my buddy kill younger
directed her for years and said and he
directed everybody literally 200 300 TV
with everybody you can think of he said
the most talented and most
improvisational uh actor he's ever
worked he's brilliant and she would come
up with [ __ ] he'd give her like she'd
come up with like a topic he said give
me a topic and he'd give her one and she
would just go and it'd be every single
time she did it for five years she hit
it every time what got her to the dance
her stand of her old stand up to me I
just thought was do those the other show
Ellen right but she was which she wasn't
gay on the sitcom Ellen right no man
when she came out in a blue teal yellow
she came out yeah and then I remember I
do get this gate from standard like oh
really yeah everyone knew well everybody
well some people yet but but of course
it was like when it was like Kevin
Spacey and these guys who you everybody
knew was bugged and not Tim Susan yeah
no I didn't know is that public Tim
Tracy gay everyone kind of knows people
are advised not out though it's like
killer to him be like what the [ __ ] yeah
I keep him to himself but by the way you
know these were things that you know we
kind of knew and everybody kind of
especially without but you guys are in a
small circle America has no idea I guess
you're right man America alright so it
was a huge deal he came out and Kevin
Spacey is coming out the prom with
demonstrations coming out to the Tony
Awards
it was probably a fight wearing these
boots we he's always had his is his
career is always dependent on him being
not gay I think there was always that
idea that what if I don't work because
57 year old
husband has been followed by gay rumors
for much of his ælis run he's never
outright confirma deny them but drinking
on Jim I feel like it's his right ever
say I feel it's his right to be silent
about it that he's private he's a
private person who gives a [ __ ] he's a
great actor and if he don't you want to
keep that out of the conversation I
totally respect that honestly yeah I
mean is anyone gonna shut him in
Hollywood for being gay no way nothing
no but but it's not that it's no it's
not that what happens is quietly and
nobody wants to really admit this is
that they do they test you you know they
test your your likability and your
appeal to audience well you he's right
even get certain roles if you have to
change it you know Wayne that yeah man
and it just happens and you can't prove
anything
yeah it just happens of constantly
people like I feel like yeah but
everybody knows he's gay so if he has to
play this love interest in this really
kind of sexy man or this powerful man
but would they're all going to be
looking at a gay man this what happened
in there right and I don't blame anybody
for it they're they're business people
Kevin Spacey's trying to put he's
supposed to play a character he wants
play along he wants to sexuality the
full of fun yeah man I mean it's like
okay now I got to fight through that
it's heard enough being a great idea
brilliant on Sicard two main pieces he's
been killing it I was watching Kevin
Spacey when he was 30 years old on stage
on Broadway in Athol Fugard plays I mean
I was watching him in New York City can
you name an actor female where it's a
fifth this career though trying to think
let me do you housing it's very very
it's very subtle right it's shuttle some
of them I can't really some of them some
are like yo here's the deal yeah it's
changed a lot in this world but it's
still your overseas appeal remember
these these actors make a lot of money
with their appeal overseas studios make
a fortune
overseas you overseas the story that's
why I don't know how a gay man's
accepted in China I don't know how a gay
man's accepted in Europe I don't know
certain error appears yes remember when
Ricky Martin Kim read that even though I
was like what Ricky Martin IP yes I
remember my mom does this a shame and
I'll tell you what it does to you I
sponsors so Greg Louganis who everybody
knew was gay came out we had AIDS deal
really dick diver yup the original dick
diver she's oh my god is the captain of
the dicta yes and he correct and and the
greatest the greatest diver of all time
well we should make an NBA logo for dick
divers but it's him diving ah yep and he
always is a kitty you hear him talking
he's really got a dad though not anymore
but did you see him when he was younger
he was really feminist feminine and this
is how he talked and he got beat up he
got teased he was crucified as a kid I
think he grew up in somewhere in central
California or maybe Southern California
around you know a lot of like tough
Latino kids and you know and in a lot of
party look you try being gay in Poland
try being gay in Russia right now so
yeah try being gay in each other in the
other countries good luck with that
so it's very alive and well if I'm being
gay himself in America it's not enough
well it ain't easy you know and there
are certain parts where it's actually
still dangerous to be gay yeah I get
that [ __ ] I can't even place what's safe
really in certain parts of the country
certain parts of the city like you mean
some trouble man yeah so guy like Matt
one is wide about a Greg Louganis hit
his head start bleeding
nope leave away yeah and you know back
then we didn't know anew nobody really
knew so when he hit his head he got cut
open the blue part was pretty good for
today yeah and he knew he drained the
pool you know he didn't think there live
the next guy was like I'm jumping in
there when he won those medals he didn't
know he didn't think he was going to
live there's a new documentary on him
yeah I saw he's living in Malibu and he
like they're trying to take his home
like he's not doing well got swindled
and I was just not doing well yes that's
a bummer he's a good person like yeah we
could do yeah I feel bad for right yeah
really good do his money problems and
you know it's just a bummer and he's er
he was he giveth the greatest diver
still is the greatest diver of all time
there's nobody who King him another one
sure Kent sure can very good the
greatest dive of all time
oh yeah who's second yeah yeah Greg
Louganis is well he's older what he was
able to do and
documentary you hear what he was able to
do for sure can you name was competitive
you can't name competitive I was he was
in a class by himself though nor yet
aids that you know like that little bit
but his skill level for sure but the
reason why most people know him because
the controversy 100% well yes but not
actually I disagree because when I was
alive I mean I remember very well when
he was I'm saying why is relevant now
yeah yeah his digestion is correct
correct correct the reason they made the
documentary isn't because he was an
amazing guy but when he doe it adds oh
it was a superstar cause he was really
looking uh and he was so good honey
medals me when something crazy like five
thousand oh you won five thousand medals
for sure looking up [ __ ]
so he's a peasant typing him it's really
bad at diving that looks funny yeah have
you seen it the Filipino diving team no
I thought it was a joke you know her
looking what is he still a good
beautiful looking guy beautiful
beautiful great body
no lame in and had a boyfriend it was a
some weird dude he didn't sociopath yes
those money and so yeah that was the
bummer geez look at that look at that
well the only one good on the world once
they countered Olympic oh well
Championships are pretty amazing too so
484 yeah so if you count Michael Phelps
World Championships he you really only
count like the world champ stirs are
good but the big knockers there are the
the gold medals so he wants for gold
many one silver he won five world gold
medals he won four gold medals and a
silver Jesus
pan-american games go blue anyway um the
Filipino daya teams I'll show a little
of it but it is hilarious oh this is
just a mess out there
yeah I don't think a compete oh is that
real it's vile no way I that sucks
ah yeah you gotta return because they
look at me huh look at me
it's 14c releases Hoffman hahahaha
Ashley that's very funny stuff they're
all bear that's then they give him a
zero oh and if it was it they displease
three why are they doing this he doesn't
look like he's ready to go I get the
story he doesn't like he's in the zone
know that no I don't know man ah what
are you so bad I think it's a new sport
and they taught us how they feel even
get excited I feel like amateur [ __ ] now
I feel this is Olympic it can't be on
Sarno if it's a hundred percent real but
from what I'm reading they're no they're
dead this isn't funny
why are they laughing up wait now listen
this is the C game yeah [ __ ] either way
whatever it's what he does I've been
million views though uh yeah but is this
he gave others purposely trying to be
shitty no no I think they just they just
never his a son he just probably wanted
to enter yeah but they're doing all the
split have you ever done any practice
your see yeah I think there's a belly
flop Olympics did you see the guy the
where he was from an African country and
it was the first time that an African
entered a swimmer in it and magic name
is from it's not good
can you put African swimmer in the
Olympics he just didn't do well on
YouTube would did he compete in diving
as I was the freshman it was he at was
it was that lastly this has to be like
alright yeah
- disaster yeah [ __ ] Neela yeah I
remember this but there are a lot of
moments the people remembers around
taking part the Olympic motto is around
taking part in pledge 5
you know the name like Eric if he'd been
an athlete he could have been an
elephant as it was two false starts and
the men's beats in the treatise on
sciences oh he was doing domain eel in
the book oh poor guy is very tough one
time a very poor country that's a bunch
oh he was people were like I don't lean
awesome because he just didn't have the
coaching man he was you know he was he
was a new sleep board for him he was in
the Congo or something yeah yeah he's
every bit I mean he's I become regular
dude high on his head in the water as
good as he is just not just what I read
him would do laughs yeah well I think I
would we be taught at it very hilarious
so he's like an icicle an hour he
drowned
he actually dropped and he died it was
like he's really struggle he didn't hire
an athlete exhausted hi it's like okay
man get the [ __ ] out of it to get out we
need a [ __ ] boom I think but know how
awesome people are looking awesome
people teasing so that's me
that would be me right I wouldn't be sad
I would be some cotton purple god bless
ya we all saw around yeah God letting
some God in like July Friday even
swimming for 15 minutes you know I mean
in his life he had 15 minutes of lessons
neck over to the hole ha ha ha do you
imagine if you're at a bar and they're
like you know he's so nosey yeah damn
yes you really get home and look him up
what's his time but 15 minutes to swim -
I was just on about 13 minutes oh yeah
I'm sorry he had a heart attack years
yeah get the [ __ ] out of the pool
try doing that in Philly ain't my place
a Michael Phelps when the same lame or
God guys oh it's so funny good to show
you how good those guys are and how
horrible
can I ask you it was honestly like
swimming I love swimming
do you think it gets too much attention
in the Olympics no I love you do you
feel that it's give you attention you
defined yourself going I don't give
to follow I think the reason go but I
would like the reason got so much
attention because Michael Phelps
dominate a minimal time yeah
so when there's an absolute winner like
that he's American huh that's why I get
so much attention they've always gotten
attention our swimming is always hot
like Michael Phelps oh I don't know
about that I think Swimming's been we
voice had be static doors right about it
Americans of always won well we had
Michael Phelps for that yet Amy van
Dyken like we've always had these
played' Missy Mr Sanders yeah like we
voice I just I can't imagine spending
that much time in a pool like that's
gonna think about I feel Phelps I mean
most dominant of alt like just as
complete stud yeah yeah Ryan Lochte like
get some monsters yeah that's why you
have so much attention also there good
cycle it so same vault like gals like
them who same ball like I like that yeah
because he's so dominant you're gonna
tune in to watch them race but like our
other sports we don't tune into because
if we're not done they will walk like
you're built like some of those spent
sprinters those the covers the swimmers
there so that ionized in just another
swim the sprinters are giant guys
there's sin though like I'm Way too
thick to be I don't know man some of
them are huge some of them are like put
up bring up some Sprint Olympics and
I'll just do just do average weight of
Olympic swimmers sprinter so they're
they're so distance guys are thinner the
swimsuit all those guys you do both
right right you're I don't know yeah so
did their different events so they're
sprinters then there's the relay right
the same guy okay because some of them
average average weight no Olympic
swimmer swimmer 100 meters winner that's
a good 100 meters from I do the same D
so there's a hundred meters there's a
two hundred those get 100 you have to
lay these misprints right on meters run
spreaders and then bring up Briella so
check it a mugful TOEFL race and win
that yeah and then do the 400 then do
the relay they're all the same team
there's only one Olympic team no no I
understand us but there's also you could
being different there's also the 10,000
meter or something right isn't there
going aren't there's a long ones like
this all of them well would they put in
a different spot so Michael Phelps might
be really good at sprinting they put him
the last leg right but there's only one
swim team there's not different oh so
they're not sprinters really they don't
have
some people are good at the 100 some
people get the foreign so we would go to
the relay right it's also only have the
the long-distance one might be I feel I
can have other ones huh 190 pounds 227
pounds a big big boy 180 no there's no
sense in man
well 227 not then 6 6 to 230 that's
pretty slow stood 6 6 to 36 220 look
that guy yo stint at 16 island bernardo
de balón bernard i think they are skinny
legs but big shoulders they're sinner
yeah people that's the wrong guy that's
the wrong guy did will just get better
at this it's
nason Adrian - got the second one down
there you go oh yeah sorry
yes renters aren't happy like big big
dudes he's big d that's a picture that's
big I however he's seen whoever he's
gone all skinny legs xyx 225 but he's
the biggest one thin and we shall blow
his body fat yeah if you look like if
you look at here I bet you they're
really skinny but there's another big
ones in not that same bubble it's pretty
big brothers he's five six percent body
fat
yeah 6 6 225 pound what I'm saying he's
got a fake same right like he's got a
big free sheet all yeah fly shoulders
they're not my size then I'll sit yeah
you're you're kinda gonna go back so
let's say he's out lighter go back to
that list yet you collect a list
what does like what's touch what if we
get the next biggest guy 198 pounds mmm
226 5 192 that's skinny yeah you're
right you're right
6 1 167 there's guys 230 he's like way
back in the days uh Morgan let's go
German dude yeah yeah you're right
though I'm tall but very thin you're
right you can't we'll just is just
physically get beat up hey Higgins thick
you know I got six for 198 let's see
what the original that looks like and
then they're lean man like I remember
like these they're worse in the French
guide to world class tasks I gave
Michael tops run for his money he's a
big boy that's very big he looks like
Mark Zuckerberg he does
musculars that short to the big like his
big shoulders and stuff yeah where he
looks enormous it is yeah they're long
they're long big guys I mean you know
what slit hurt they're long and thin
yeah well you just can't be a real thick
so the Olympic water polo players those
are big boys
those guys are as big as you are
sometimes yeah if you look kind of like
a soccer burger and Michael Phelps he
does he looks like Michael Phelps and
Zucker had a baby look at go here
Coldplay yeah not really he looks more
like like a bigger Michael Phelps yeah
and Coldplay um yeah those Walsh was the
endurance was like those polar bear
tried water polo yeah beef it's a
[ __ ] yeah they lift a lot away
say the size is good because they kind
of donkey truck depends on the position
- yeah yeah yeah that's a look I saw the
greeting wrong [ __ ] huge I was like
Jesus Christ like the Serbians forget it
go to our water polo team gin water polo
in a California the [ __ ] are
good to the schools here yep one of my
my son place and water polo boys a
beating right around Shattuck boys it's
a back shot again though their legs like
they have thin legs I think but you know
be yellow remember the all these these
things you keep saying with their big
boys its endurance like if they're so
they can't have psyche they can you say
it like when you say big I think to me
big would be NFL like yeah that's not
endured sport right
so he said swimmers are not big like
I've seen yeah compared I feel like a
Phelps I've seen Ryan like they're not
big guy really
they're not big there's they're very
thin you remember you're talking about
he got on Conor you got a move yet so it
doesn't make sense when we'll say big ty
it's not NFL football but it's not it's
not professional athlete big right
they're not big people right well there
you go
they're kind of like not one of those
guys yeah big app yeah yeah just because
it takes it again it you can't use you
shouldn't have that much other
right that's common sense I guess you're
in the water for that long you can't be
a big guy well it's kind of soccer you
can't have that much weight on you know
it'd be such a disadvantage to write
sick dude right but you're not helping
with your buoyancy with that or fat like
how you float buoyancy well yeah well
that's why that's why your pointy is a
little bit more about a body type right
so you're selfish ready so if you have
more fat you me slow in the water if you
work matically less well she had yeah
it'll be more buoyant that's for sure
if you have an extra layer of fat you
are more buoyant if you're really
muscular and shredded you tend to not be
as buoyant see that that ends that e'er
yeah it muscle sinks fat floats kind of
idea so it's like it's a body type to
body type you know babies are all fat
there isn't flow oh um yeah a lot of us
do technique that's what those guys are
in shape you're a bit of a seal that ya
seen you take to the water I love me
some water men grow you fast Lisa pretty
fast I mean I love swimming man in the
ocean everything you don't look like a
swimmer Jackie cannot swim you can't
swim I know how to swim but not really
well I panic I did a lot of swimming as
a kid you seem like you could swim yeah
yeah most kids I feel like especially
like if you don't learn how to swim when
your kids come screwed I was on the swim
team as a kid when I was in eighth grade
it's kind of screwed if you're not if
you don't do this kids not like then
pick up as an adult how did you learn
though I mean life just wasn't anybody
like my grandma ever every like weekend
[ __ ] we'd go to this like community pool
kids will stay in a pool for five hours
yes that was like our day kill yeah
dad's bringing us family yeah the other
day all daily sleep at night all day
long that's right you are in a pool
outside swimming where yeah my kids will
be in the pool for five hours six hours
I'm not kidding they will stay in the
pool jumping out coming out come on need
something and then Kapow back in B I get
a gobo
because it damn it you have to do
current events and I don't mind
oh and dropping knowledge flighted low
45 yeah you're going to take the world
by snow
um yeah um why didn't we Lisa I really
have no idea what's not that early I
don't know if chance will be necessarily
about because here do your airports 15
minutes away I know but this is my cars
down there yeah let's make it wait you
think yeah I mean if you want just you
do crinum at 15 minutes it's up to you I
don't want it exactly I don't mind at
all I can handle it no problem this is
fun the people are clamoring for me
while you guys do that I'll go ahead and
load the first one and it's a terrible
one oh boy I just saw this today
hundreds confessed to eating human flesh
in South Africa cannibals there's a sign
how do the people allegedly confessed to
eating human flesh given to them by one
of the men facing cannibals in charge
since other advice - the thing on this
go did it yeah are you incapable yeah so
so legitimate during the war during the
war um in this there's this idea that
you could if you ate for example this is
terrible a child's heart yet they're
palatable yeah that's what they're
saying here so they would kill innocent
children and eat their hearts it's hell
on earth it's what was so you're saying
this is going on right now
yeah they say one of the guys went up to
the police station with body parts and
said I don't want to do this anymore
yeah yeah and also the guy the main guy
who found God and that was a preacher he
was a general in he was a human eating
of he would eat children's hearts she's
like that now I found Jesus and [ __ ] you
yeah I go to hell this is I think this
was in the Congo or in Liberia I begin
to be periodic for meeting human uh yeah
you can get a visa brain your [ __ ] yes
you look at cuckoo you laughing disease
I'm at County a mess basically right
yeah towels we get it from you and each
other's brain yeah so typically if you
look at for example the Old Testament
they always talked about not eating
never eating the flesh of an animal that
eat other animals and there's a lot of
scientific reasons for that so if you
eat something that like an osprey an
eagle or a bear that eats dead
carcasses you'll get trichinosis you'll
get all kinds of things you yeah you get
all kinds of weird wheats people man
this is an Africa yeah it's an Africa
because I'm sure here is a also
education and well because what happens
is somebody says by the way to eat an
innocent child's heart you bullet is
bounced off Jason you've never had any
education you're a kid that was taken by
a group and turned into a child soldier
and you do that and this is what happens
in life this is this is what happens
when order and everything breaks down
what does what happens in war on a
lighter note
Demi Lovato is tagged to sing or tapped
to sing the national anthem I love love
how do I love it in everywhere I love
her thinks she's amazing who's gonna
sing the island national anthem I don't
know cuz you gotta [ __ ]
I don't think not should I tell her she
would crazy man she were a little dark
right he was in a motel did a video
saying she wanted to kill herself
yeah did you see the video that Tyson
Fury posted afterwards not very sweet he
was saying like you know you're going to
hard times I know you're going through
this now he suffers from mental illness
- oh did he posted a thing for her yeah
but a very sweet message yeah call me if
you need anything a wild alright no it's
reaiiy things recent very reason yeah
because she posted one very recent all
another one yeah he says she tweeted
something yes but she did it Bolivia or
she said you know I'm lost I'm really
it's really yeah I'm only staying alive
for my psychiatrist was st. it says I
mean snow let me see the original Sinead
O'Connor when I would go [ __ ] would you
know doesn't feel it's crazy just
talking to crazy yeah she's really not
doing well tough one man hit this one
yeah living in motel so click on that we
have New Jersey New Jersey
kidneys dude hold on myself I'm just
absolutely no D in my living so sad
doctor I can't stop it yeah it's such a
bummer
there's no one there that's despair all
by yourself yeah that's just despair
there's no friends affair
I think people like that isolate
themselves and they keep people away
because of a lot of who knows I'm such a
bum suffering from that and so let me
see Tyson fear Woody's day
said this is Tyson theory form
undisputed heavyweight champion in the
world and this is a special message to
Sanae tell coma recently watch one of
y'all how heartbreaking videos we talked
about mental health problems I've been
alone I'm feeling like it wasn't a role
model and it wasn't your fault and no
one's there I recently been going
through a lot of it myself it's made and
you're not alone there's a lot of people
out there go for the same thing like you
say millions of people around the world
suffer with this mental problems is one
of the worst things that anyone could
ever unlawful telling and I'm so
successful or H you become mental health
will always bring you down and it always
gives someone a right to write you off
whether reason but I'm here if you need
me Tyson Fury got someone to come talk
to me I'd like to uh speak to you as a
good friend who's sweet right yeah I
think unless she offers unless unless
you suffer from it you have no idea what
I yeah yeah like this would be I can't
release them now in the you know I'm
gonna take a real bump I'm interest rate
of sickness that it's accurate sickness
and I've have had family members that
are that way we really like elbow and
you can't help them it's really tough
with us get actually help with this one
um so a woman says she had got cancer
from using talcum powder debate the
Johnson & Johnson's baby powder
yeah and she actually won four and
seventeen million dollars from it good
cause it they've linked that to cancer
cervical cancer in the shot and get
cancer really
oh well and then there's like the fourth
lawsuit so it's for feminine hygiene
when you know yeah we put on it she
ain't into getting cancer what I had no
idea
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah hold on
about talking about ass potential cancer
risk that's crazy
cancel dad's nuts
I guess give me one more chin I'd roll
all right hand to mouth good one
you know anyone with peanut allergies
kids yep a lot of them a lot of kids who
are having kids help my kids downline
yeah but but I just do it's it's it's
actually to the point where if you open
some kids because it has the same effect
that Sinai does if you open a peanut
about thinga peanut and the scent of the
peanut can actually send a clear animal
it's crazy you know squares only almond
butter now there's yeah you get it on
kids skin they can go on anaphylactic
shock Jesus but I mean the other pens up
to Wyatt needles for the keys yeah an
EpiPen Australian scientists this is a
study they did over four years seventy
percent of the kids were healed it's
just adding probiotics with the beam
well so it's not trying to like fight
thick the allergy old uncle builds their
new system that's working you can do
that with our snake venom by the way
that's right yeah little little kind of
to get it's tough to get snake venom did
you just cure some tiny doses I'm very
odd about it's like a tough gig day yeah
help that snake yeah in case you in case
you get bit by snake yeah case you're in
the wild you got this beef I got a boat
you gonna have fun make me proud okay
alright buddy
alright let me just just hold on all
right hold on
well like Brennan is gone and I'm about
to take over this [ __ ] you're welcome
everybody let's keep going through some
ah you know current events Corinne
events with to whom see what's going on
mm-hmm
damn right okay the next one another
underage girl has reported that she had
sex with our Kelly she's a 15 year old
girl damn and that just came out so is
he on trial right now
or no see I don't know if he was
actually officially charged with that
cult thing well was he was there a video
of him peeing all that on us our
ten-year old I don't know how you bounce
back
you know there are guys that can't
bounce back from the fact that they
allegedly sexually harassed somebody and
then their careers are ruined right so
he he she came in he said hot chocolate
or you know you know he said great dress
or whatever it might be or oh he touched
her face and he got fired and he was the
CEO this happens all the time yeah so
some people just can't get away from
that our Kelly is caught on video
I haven't seen the video but this is
what I heard pissing on a girl who's 14
I mean you know like guess what dude for
me we'll see you later yeah I mean I
whether or not whether you beat the
charges in a courtroom you know I just
can't have you at my party anymore you
know what I mean it's not going to buy
your music but somehow we just don't
talk about it it's something weird some
like a music artist too just like Chris
Brown be beating like Rihanna even that
with Chris Brown none of us know the
details so what happens is we go lover's
spat
you know they got in a fight you know
all everybody knows somebody who like a
couple that's really volatile love each
other and they pup fight sometimes they
hit each other you know it's like well
good luck with that but we're all like
jeez you know that's that's like you you
I don't if you don't see that and you
think well they're these two stars that
are crazy in love and yeah he had to go
to anger management stuff if that's a
story that we all have heard a thousand
times so we put it into context we're
like adults fighting you know yeah he's
he's he loved her she gave him something
or you know whatever it is there's
always these reasons this kind of [ __ ]
man is to me a little bit different
because it involves a child you know or
at least a 14-year old or whatever so I
don't know but both of that but
definitely this is I don't know yeah
again though again by the way I don't
know I need to see the facts I need to
see what's really going on here how much
of this is hearsay
how much of this is conjecture I don't
know you
the guy got off right you know it's a
strange thing then it's a strange thing
anyways let's move on from this have you
seen the story on a family that had a
Norman Rockwell painting kit just
hanging in their living room they didn't
realize it was an actual original that's
amazing and I guess their nephew once
you get it tested and it's worth 1.6
million there you go there you go ladies
and gentlemen that's amazing and what do
you think of this okay honestly what do
you think of this if Floyd Mayweather
and Justin Bieber were really good
friends and then Justin Bieber recently
unfollowed him on Instagram because his
church is telling that he's a bad you
know influence okay and then flowing
made with her apparently
the rumors are he went like ballistic
well I'm like this is this is horrible
you know I was there for you when you're
going through your stuff whatever now
this is happening before the fight do
you think this is at all affects him in
the fight
no like emotionals you know I think when
Floyd Mayweather steps in the ring all
his problems melt away I think the one
place that flirting mebut Mayweather has
no problems and then one place
Floyd Mayweather feels safe and the one
place for Mayweather is allowed to be
truly himself is in that ring and you
know when he's talking about fighting
Conor McGregor he's like just another
day for me that makes sense when you
master something and you're that good
you you are it is just another day you
know competition on that level I mean he
sees it's what he does that's a language
he has mastered it's a language he's
fluent in and it's a language where he's
seen everything you're going to throw at
him so you know the Justin Bieber thing
might even be if he's a shrewd guy it
might even be part of like you know part
of the media storm that he's creating
right I mean you turn it into something
important does he really care that
Justin Bieber unfollowed him I don't
know he's at him talking you know
somebody unfollowed me I you know please
no these are just leaders from from
people they know you me ask you this
have you ever you know
most have happening because you've been
performing on stages everywhere have you
ever had like a really messed up
argument or something bad happened
before you went on stage and you were
able to just be in your own world
afterwards it did it affect you um if I
feel like in my life I haven't closed a
circle or taken care of something you
know if I have unfinished business if
somebody is upset with me because I did
something wrong yeah like that if
somebody thinks I did something wrong
and I haven't addressed it and it's
hanging in the air I have a big problem
with that
I don't like unfinished business I don't
like having things I want to say to
somebody close to me that I haven't said
I don't like when I'm in the wrong and
I'd haven't admitted to it or made it
better or made it right that's a big
problem for me I like I always want to
have paid my debts and I think that's
where a lot of stress comes from and
when I haven't done that it's a form of
lying right when I'm not when I haven't
confronted something that that needs to
be confronted when I'm procrastinating
my back will hurt and my shoulder will
start twitching it's really weird
literally I started doing this weird
thing with my left shoulder so those are
my telltale it slides that you have to
close a circle you know I call it
closing circles you got to have all your
circles closed one of the things I like
about like my fiftieth birthday or my
wedding or any of those moments is I
invite everybody I know who means
something to me
and I make sure all those relationships
are whole and that everything is
completed I love that and it's important
to me it's really important to me you
know I want to I want to think that I'm
doing the right thing it's very very
important and so I do and it's also why
keeping negative [ __ ] out of your
life and negative people out of your
life is so crucial because there are a
lot of people that that I guess you love
and they love you but there's it's not a
real relationship they're suppressive
they're just suppressive because your
relationship could be an older sister
younger sister could be your mother
could be a family member usually
somebody very close to your will
quote-unquote best friend and every time
you're around them you're not really
yourself you're playing a character
you're living double life
because they are a suppressive force on
you they're those people that are
essentially you know they're judgmental
they can't really deal with you unless
they're over you they can't have a
really and equal relationship with you
and you know those people and we all
have them in our lives I think those
people are very important to keep an
arm's length you don't have to cut them
out of your life completely
keeping the [ __ ] away from you if you
want to get things done because they're
going to bring you down this is not new
science but I'm a big believer and kind
of protecting yourself and I'm also a
really big believer in standing up for
yourself in those situations where you
know you're like hey dude you know I'm a
good guy but don't mistaken my kindness
for weakness you know go [ __ ] yourself
at the end of the day don't do that you
have to have lines you have to have
clearly stated boundaries and I'm I've
never been somebody who's terribly
sensitive that way I don't I'm not a
competitive person you know I'm just not
I don't like the idea of competition
like that like um if you play a game
with me you know you know you beat me
it's no big deal I don't care I'm more
competitive with myself am I am I being
the best comic I can be am i writing a
lot that's that's a different thing so
yeah anyway you are a good person though
I mean I gotta see behind all this dusty
so I appreciate them daggit oh for sure
well that's important to me i I think
I'm a good person you know I mean I hope
I do the right thing it's like it's like
the same thing with when we advertise
things on this on this show we say look
no to a lot of stuff because I don't I
have to I have to believe in it it's got
to be a product I'm not law I can't lie
to our audience I can't because you know
it has nothing to do with getting away
with it or not I just you know it's that
would hurt my back I'd be moving my
shoulder a lot I would you know I'd say
I don't want to be that guy you because
we all do this [ __ ] man you ever like
you ever talk you ever say you ever
talking in a way like you'll say you do
something because it's the ideal of who
you want to be but you realize you don't
really do
that if we all do that [ __ ] all the time
like I don't know I'm trying to think of
an example of what I do when I do that
but anyway but the negative thing I
totally agree with I remember I had well
when you're on say I don't use Facebook
that much anymore but when you used to
be on Facebook there's like a timeline
whatever's you know it's just like in
strength letter post something it pops
up and then I have certain friends that
post you know complaining about this and
that and after a while I started I get I
get bummed out about it so I would you
can actually filter it to where you
don't see their posts anymore okay and I
feel I feel should so many posts out of
like oh yeah now you know - Brennan and
I were obviously are very close but
that's how that's a relationship that
always every relationship needs to be
tended to every relationship needs to be
gardened you know because this this show
is is very contingent upon us being true
friends and as having fun experiences
and and being close and that's very
bored so then when when he's really busy
he's Marilyn for a long time and I'm
doing my thing and we're we haven't seen
each other in two weeks
we got a regroup man we got to regroup
and check in and kind of see what's
going on with each other because
otherwise and there's no there's no way
to get out of that you've got to
confront [ __ ] it's something's bugging
you or whatever yeah you got to talk it
out because the show is contingent upon
honesty and a real relationship and a
real friendship and a lot of us don't
hold ourselves to that standard because
we don't have to but marriage is that
way you got kids with a woman you better
be talking those things out you better
be I [ __ ] up this morning my kid was
nervous about his first day in school
and I started roughhousing with him and
then he got it he kicked me and I go hey
and I grad I scolded him he started
crying my wife is like you can't do that
I've got this kid already he's nervous
about school you're scolding him right
before he goes to school what you know I
mean she goes he's not that guy you want
him to be this boy who you can
roughhouse with he's way too sensitive
for that sorry he's not that kid for you
you know
I I had to I had to go I'm sorry yeah I
was wrong
I [ __ ] up you know you have to do that
otherwise my wife is going to be angry
with me and that's not gonna work out
I'm gonna pay a price anyway moving on
more current events hell yeah like him
this is a good story and usually I don't
know I didn't post a Matt Hughes stuff
for a while cuz I guess you know where
he's recovering but his friend recently
posted a video of him well I kind of
this is just like lightly that's all
Wessling he's back on the mat yeah but
no not really really on the mat he was
just there just trying to videotape him
kind of like just having a little fun
with his friend but I mean just that
alone he was in a coma like not too long
ago oh my god so so a guy here he's just
laying on there just kind of like
lightly playing that's crazy that is
what I mean from where he looks so
skinny yeah
look at how skinny he is yeah he doesn't
look like Matt Hughes but it's good to
see that though that's amazing dude that
is amazing I loved for five days and
come back to his ass one and able to
roll I can't believe he's I thought he
was done yeah it was looking bad for a
little long have you ever had a friend
um like be injured like that no no I
haven't and I can't imagine you know but
it's really great to see him doing that
because that it was a serious brain
injury you know yeah so it was good it's
a it's actually amazing I cannot believe
that working his muscles and stuff he
looks different
yeah man how is he who's in bed for two
months it feels like it's only been like
that long that's a great story man he's
a great guy I had the privilege of
working with him and spending time with
him on Kingdom yeah he's such a good guy
man just a just a real really good
person and a man heard he's like strong
as hell to he all I know is
I tried to grab him and he grabbed my
the back of my neck and I was like holy
[ __ ] you know farm boy strength yeah um
I don't know this UFC fighter but he got
a ten month suspension for popping for
five different sub five different things
that were not allowed yeah well you know
that's called it's called trying to get
an edge with sports and enhancing drugs
so five banned substances yeah um but I
guess I guess they were able to find
like a supplements that he was using and
both supplements that he's using had all
those five supplements in it that didn't
have it all natural label so wait so
what do you mean so he was using a
supplement that was a over-the-counter
okay and then it had those five banned
substances inside that stuff Oh Rogan
talks about this all the time
these things that build muscle that you
can get a lot of times a lot of times
they build muscle they really do because
they have steroids in them yeah because
a lot of stuff is not regulated you know
not to do an on it ad right now but
that's why on it is something you can
trust because I'm telling you because
Rogan uses it Aubrey uses it like the
people that created it use the product
every day I seen it with my own eyes
they they are always obsessed with
purities obsessed with where its sources
they're obsessed with all of that stuff
and that's that's why you know I we've
had way before honor came along I on my
podcast and fire and kid we had a lot of
supplement companies come to us and I
was like I can't trust you guys I don't
know what you're putting it I don't know
you do you have double-blind studies in
other words you know a double-blind
study is yeah where where the person
giving you the thing doesn't know what
he's giving you and you don't know what
you're getting I need to see measurable
results and I need to see peer-reviewed
result otherwise I don't trust your
product I don't know where you're making
it I don't know what your protein powder
hasn't I don't know what your your your
testosterone building product hasn't it
chances are it probably like a lot of
the viagra you get over the the counter
and gas stations that has actual Agra
stuff yeah narcotics said that open
blood vessels
you know the same stuff that's in viagra
so yeah you know it's like these guys
who get propecia or viagra from China or
from countries where it's cheaper cool I
don't know what's in it how much is in
it you know who's regulating this [ __ ]
don't trust it
I'll stick with American pharmaceutical
companies or you know come from schools
companies it whether it's there's a
chain of you know you can follow the
yeah we're sourced do you think that
there's a chance because I kind of think
this is about how it's going on so these
guys that are doing these
over-the-counter supplements yeah I
think a lot of them they know through
people that some of these supplements
have actual things that they would want
but if they're ready I caught they could
show hey it's not on the bottle but you
know people talk yeah people in certain
circles talk I'm just I'm kind of
thinking some of these people that get
pops4
you know substances that are in actual
over-the-counter supplements right I
know that that's doesn't that stuff's in
there but that's just this easy way out
yeah do you believe that or not ah yeah
sometimes I don't know but I do I could
I you know I don't know it's hard to
tell what's in a bottle you know so and
I also think the reality is that when
you do professional sports especially
MMA on that level where your your
training that hard it's it's I'm really
forgiving a lot of times of people who
use steroids
I just am I you know because I think
it's it's really hard to stay injury
free
it's really hard to have a career that
lasts a long time when you're not
getting help it's just it's probably it
bare it breaks you down then so I know
people are really you know they're like
you know they're there unforgiving about
the stuff but that's usually people who
don't do sports and or haven't done
sports on a high level I haven't either
but I've seen what they go through man
it's really really difficult I know for
a fact Brennan's never done that stuff
but he has a certain body type you know
I don't know I
and I'm not saying it's not cheating but
I am saying that I I get it and I'd be
probably a lot more lenient I don't know
the answer I'm actually I'm actually
torn on the use of steroids in sport
because if you really allowed it to go
anywhere you wanted you'd have people
with pharmacists and the guy with the
best doctor and the best farmer this
would be the guy with the gold medal
that's just a fact because if you have
two people of equal physical caliber and
skill the guy with the better drugs is
going to win right depending on the
sport you know but so you do have to
have I mean I get I think his name is no
Vince key I get I get you sadhas' point
of view I get the idea of strict testing
I get it
it's it's probably better for the
athletes in some ways their health in
the long run because athletes will do
whatever it takes to get that edge as
Brendan says they'll eat a piece of [ __ ]
if it gets them over the finish line
faster you know it's just it's the
nature of athletes pro athletes they'll
they'll die
you know Nate Marquart was talk will
talk about the Eids but he was willing
to die in that in that cage you have to
protect athletes from themselves
sometimes so I don't I don't like that
thing where you have to report every
where you're going I think that it's
very invasion they'll show up at 3:30
4:30 5:30 in the morning they'll just
bang on your door I mean I know fighters
have told me a story there's also if you
go anywhere you have to let yes I'll let
them know everywhere you're going yes
that's terrible yeah it's very it's very
invasive the question is how do you
prevent I mean how do you avoid that if
you actually really want testing you've
got to be pretty draconian about it so I
don't know yeah I don't know well that's
all we got for current events unless you
got something I just have a funny
dropping knowledge a lot of these white
supremacists there's a website I think a
300,000 people actually belonged to it
and it's called Stormfront and you can't
belong to stormfront unless you are of
pure european ancestry and a lot of them
are doing this 23 to me the thing I did
like the Gino we spit in the cup and
there they're not happy with the results
a lot of might just have so much [ __ ]
they got Asian they got you know
they got Jewish they got all kinds of
stuff like like it is like it is you
know you you if you look at cross
migrations of populations and stuff
there are so many different types of you
know you know we we did a lot of inter
mixing that's what the human race is you
know you have probably a lot of
Mongolian you have all kinds of in you
and you know this idea of purity is so
laughable and stupid and in fact not
even a good thing
what do you mean purity what are you
talking about so you can trace your
lineage all the way back to the Saxons
to the original Vikings all right I
guess it means you you won't have any
rhythm you suck it and you suck in the
Sun you can't handle spices you ever see
like I do this joke about Vikings when
they even even black pepper they're like
but it's too too much for them I mean
you know you you develop a lot of
resistance to diseases because you have
a mixture of a lot of different kind of
races one of the problems with the
Ashkenazi Jews is that they are because
they were so marginalized they bred with
each other there was a lot of you know
sort of clannish tight-knit
interbreeding if you will among among
people who are strictly of Jewish faith
and it created a lot of genetic
abnormalities that led to a higher
incidence of breast cancer in some cases
and all kinds of stuff so it's always
been known by geneticists and even
doctors that if you have a good mix if
you're a mutt
you're probably going to have a better
chance of resisting disease the same
goes with dogs in fact pure breeds have
a lot of problems that mutts don't
because for whatever reason when you
cross pollinate genes you you are
stronger and by the way the reason that
human beings progress is because ideas
have sex idea sex the appropriation and
cross-pollination of cultures is how you
get really [ __ ] good food and how you
get people smarter
because you know what makes you a better
fighter
when you borrow techniques from the
Russians from the Brazilians from the
American boxers from the Mexicans from
the Thai and you mix it all together and
you get mixed martial arts do the same
thing with your mix mental arts that's
why my podcast mixed mental arts is a
podcast about learning how to think
broadly be a mixed mental artist new
episode drops very soon another way but
it that's my mission I don't make any
money on mixed mental arts but I try to
I try and we have a website mix metal
arts CO and we try to essentially
distill the big ideas look there are 130
million books out there and sixty
million scientific papers that's a
conservative estimate oh and by the way
there's the internet with all that
information how the hell are you
supposed to learn or know anything well
I am trying with the help of very smart
people to at least break down some big
ideas and get the seminal books the
books that started everything read and
you not to read them but I'm trying to
break them down and distill them with
articles and things like that some other
people that's what the websites about
but but be a mixed mental artist be a
mixed martial artist be a be a mixed
artist artist you know make your life a
work of art and you can't do that unless
you you appropriate other people's ideas
customs cultures unless you expand your
understanding which means read broadly
listen broadly don't be so quick to join
a team please because when you join a
team when you adhere to an ideology you
are going to not really do your own
thinking you're going to let the leader
of that ideological movement do most of
the thinking for you and histories would
suggest that that turns you into either
a fanatic or into a corpse
so think for yourself treat everybody as
an individual read broadly listen
broadly eat everything eat everything
turn your life into a work of art and
that's it for this is the fighter in the
kid oh hold on oh hold on there you go
oh god I'm going to be in Cincinnati at
this brouhaha Cincinnati comedy festival
at the Sawyer I think it's the Sawyer
point theater main stage at the brouhaha
this Friday
come see me I'm headlining the brouhaha
Cincinnati comedy festival 2020 first
22nd 23rd I'm in Madison Wisconsin the
comedy of the state get your tickets now
at T fat K calm I'll also be in Philly
at helium comedy club September 28 29 30
there it is August 25th August 25th
Friday since he brouhaha that's where
I'm at and I'll be at the Sawyer the
Sawyer since a Sawyer Point Park
mainstage figure it out I'll be bringing
heat we got the Sklar brothers
we got what's-his-name got some big
comics all right Tom Green lots of guys
well this is the fight or the kid we're
out